it took the world's most powerful laser
of more than a decade of effort but
researchers in the U.S have finally done
it their machine created a nuclear
fusion reaction and crucially got more
energy out of it than they had to put in
last week for the first time they
designed this experiment so that the
fusion fuel stayed hard enough dense
enough and round enough for long enough
that it ignited and it produced more
energies than the lasers had deposited
about two megajoules in about three Mega
joules out a gain of 1.5
Fusion is the reaction that powers our
sun finally proving energy can be made
from it here on Earth is a major
breakthrough for an increasingly crowded
Fusion field
there are several national projects and
more than 30 private Fusion Ventures
this company in Oxfordshire says it's
aiming to produce electrical power from
Fusion as early as the 2030s
this machine recently hit a significant
Milestone it got to a temperature of 100
million degrees at the center of the
reactor now that's six times hotter than
the Sun so when it's running this lab in
Oxford becomes the hottest place in the
solar system the swirling glow in the
center of their reactor is a plasma
super hot ions of gas the conditions
necessary for Fusion to occur theirs is
just one of many competing reactor
designs but the team here say it's Edge
comes down to its world-leading magnets
needed to recreate the gravitational
forces found in the Sun the benefit that
these HTS magnets deliver is the ability
to generate extremely high magnetic
fields and to operate at elevated
temperatures that really make for an
efficient and compact reactor the
smaller you can make a reactor the more
cost effective it will be and in the
development phase it means we can get
there faster but the science challenges
of sustaining Fusion for months not
seconds then converting their energy
into electricity for the great are so
huge some other Fusion scientists argue
none of the commercial Fusion Ventures
is likely to succeed they are a very
long way away from being at the scale
necessary to generate fusion power from
from their devices and so in order to do
that you need to be at the scale of the
ETA plant where we where we are today
and when you get up to those scales life
gets very much more complicated
eater the machine he's referring to is a
publicly funded International
collaboration that's building a power
plant scale Fusion device this root
commercial Fusion is several decades
away
whether a smaller commercial reactor can
beat this approach is very much an open
question but today Fusion science took a
big step forward Tom Clark Sky News